Good afternoon. And just to let you know, this QR code up here
will let you submit questions, which we will address at the panel session at the
very end. And I'll just give it a few minutes if you want to capture the QR
code with your phone if you're interested, and then they're going to put this slide
back up towards the end as well.
All right, so welcome to this AACR Advances in
Population Sciences session, entitled "Advances in the Use of
Geospatial and Neighborhood Data for Cancer Population Sciences
Research and Translation." And my name is Trang Vo- Pham.
I will be serving as chair.
The objectives of this session are to, one, provide background
information on geospatial science concepts and methods, and
two, to discuss contemporary examples of geospatial
applications in cancer research, specifically related to
factors in the natural, built,
and social environments of the exposome, with an emphasis
on developments, perspectives, and challenges spanning
etiology to translation. And a note that this session is being
recorded, so if you miss anything, you'll be able to view this session online
through October.
This is a 90-minute session comprised of three
20-minute-ish presentations, followed by a 25-minute
panel discussion for Q&A.
And the first talk, presented by me, is entitled "A Primer for
Geospatial Science Analytics in Cancer Research and Translation." The second
talk from Dr. Jamie Hart will cover the impact of the environment and your
neighborhood on cancer risk and survival, and the third talk from Dr.
Iona Chang will cover structural and social drivers of health.
To briefly introduce our speakers, so I'm Trang Vo- Pham.
I'm an associate professor in the epidemiology program in the Public Health
Sciences Division at the Fred Hutchinson Cancer Center, or Fred Hutch.
I'm also an affiliate associate professor of epidemiology at the University of
Washington. My research focuses on investigating environmental risk
factors for cancer using geospatial science, and I serve as PI
of the Geospatial Exposome Lab at the Fred Hutch, and as chair of the
Social and Environmental Working Group for MOSAIC, which is a new
prospective cohort study recruiting at least 11,500
Asian-American, Native Hawaiian, and Pacific Islander individuals across the
US, funded by NHLBI and other NIH
institutes. Dr. Jamie Hart is an associate
professor of medicine at Brigham and Women's Hospital and Harvard Medical
School. She's also an associate professor of environmental health at the Harvard
T.H. Chan School of Public Health, and her research focuses on the
impact of the exposome on risk of chronic disease and
health behaviors. She co-leads the Harvard Spatial and Contextual
Exposomics and Epidemiology Lab.
She serves as co-editor-in-chief of the journal "Environmental Epidemiology."
She is a fellow of the International Society for
Environmental Epidemiology,
is director of the Geographic and Contextual Measures for the
Nurses' Health Studies, and is the scientific director of the Growing Up Today
study.
And Dr. Iona Chang is a full professor and head of the
Cancer Epidemiology Division in the Department of Epidemiology and
Biostatistics at the University of California, San Francisco.
Her research focuses on understanding the roles of genetics and
molecular factors, health behaviors, environmental exposures,
and structural and social determinants of health on cancer incidence and
mortality. She is co-leader of the DREAM Lab, which stands for
Disparities Research, Environment, and Multi-Omics.
She is MPI of the new ASPIRE, Asian-American Prospective Cohort
Study, funded by NCI,
and is an investigator of the Greater Bay Area Cancer Registry,
the Colon Cancer Family Registry, the Multi-Ethnic Cohort Study, and the
RESPOND Study on prostate cancer.
So both Doctors Hart and Chang bring an outstanding wealth of deep
expertise relevant to the session today.
And next up are our three presentations.
So this first talk is entitled "A Primer for Geospatial
Science Analytics in Cancer Research and Translation," and I have
nothing to disclose.
This talk will cover the following three questions to
provide a high-level, modern-day lay of the
land of geospatial analytics in cancer population sciences.
First, what role does geospatial science play in the exposome of cancer?
Next, how is geospatial science being utilized to
answer research questions in contemporary cancer epidemiology,
with a focus on showcasing recent studies in the past one to three years?
And last, what are ways to translate epidemiologic findings
to improve population health using geospatial science?
So one of the fundamental concepts underlying modern-day
environmental epidemiology is summarized in this equation.
A phenome as the set of all phenotypes, the genome as the
genetic element of this equation, and then the exposome, which, as
you may know, is defined as the totality of a person's environmental
exposures, comprised of environmental factors in the personal
environment, such as lifestyle, factors in the natural environment, such
as climate change factors like wildfires, in the built environment, such as
green space, and in the social environment, such as neighborhood poverty,
across one's life course from conception to death.
And how can we measure exposure to factors in the
exposome to conduct epidemiologic research?
In our conceptual framework, published in 2024, we describe how
factors in the exposome domains of the personal, natural, built, and social
environments can be measured using different methods.
For example, through internal assessment methods, such as
multi-omics for different biological systems.And through external
assessment methods, such as questionnaires and geospatial science.
And geospatial science involves using
technologies that harness location-based information for
numerous applications, including mapping and visualization,
identifying hotspots, developing environmental exposure models,
and linking together different geospatial data for analysis.
And GIS, which you may have heard of, or geographic information systems, is
a very common geospatial tool used in this work.
Geospatial data are used to represent any features in our
environment according to their locations.
So for example, we have geospatial data to represent where the
individuals in a study population are located based on their
geocoded residential address, geocoded meaning assigned latitude and longitude,
based on their census tracts for neighborhoods, this is in the US, or their
county of residence in the US. And we also have geospatial
data to represent factors in the exposome.
For example, air pollution concentrations, environmental noise
levels, and neighborhood deprivation.
Now, where exactly do geospatial data come from?
So, for locations of individuals, sources and examples
include existing prospective cohort studies like the Women's Health Initiative,
administrative databases such as Medicare claims, and cancer
registries such as Surveillance, Epidemiology, and End Results, or the SEER
program.
And for factors in the exposome, geospatial data
sources and examples include remote sensing, meaning data captured from a distance,
such as satellite imagery. For example, air pollution data from the
Atmospheric Composition Analysis Group shown here.
From environmental measurements, such as for noise from the National Park
Service, and from surveys, such as from the Census Bureau American Community
Survey.
And geospatial
science can then be used to link together these different
geospatial data sets on participant locations and on
exposome factors to determine levels of exposure
in a population, such as for an exposure assessment in an epidemiologic
study.
And publications applying these approaches for cancer research
specifically have increased over time, shown in this figure created using
data from PubMed. So with close to 3,000 papers in
2025, really demonstrating the utility of geospatial science
in cancer population research,
population sciences.
And for example, recent studies have used geospatial science to answer
questions, including where are cancer hotspots?
What features are associated with these hotspots?
And do we observe geographic disparities?
For example, this study, published in 2024, used
mortality data for all cancers combined
from the US Centers for Disease Control and Prevention, or CDC,
to investigate spatiotemporal cancer clusters, incorporating
time through calculating change in rates.
And the author has identified hotspot areas, shown in red here, where
rates have increased over time. They also identified cold spot areas
in blue, so where rates have decreased over time.
And then they linked these clusters with geospatial data on
various features, including healthcare access from the sources listed below,
finding that certain variables in the figure to the right here were associated
with hotspots, including education and mammography screening.
This study, published in 2023 in JAMA Oncology,
created maps to delineate areas within two
hours of centers offering fertility preservation
services in the US, so in blue in the top map.
And then they determined the number of reproductive-age females
living outside of those areas, who thus lack geographic access to
an oncofertility center, shown in darker colors in the bottom map.
And then the authors determined that states without active or pending
legislation at the time for insurance mandates to cover fertility
preservation had the lowest rates of geographic access.
And then they identified the areas around the US with the greatest
disparities in geographic access to care.
So, just a really nice study layering many different geospatial data sets.
Recent studies have also used geospatial science to answer questions
regarding what geospatially assessed factors in the exposome are
associated with cancer.
For example, this study, published in 2024 in JAMA
Oncology, examined the association between census block
group level neighborhood deprivation index at the time of diagnosis.
This index is comprised of data from the American Community Survey, such as on
poverty and female-headed households with children.
And they looked at this in relation to breast cancer-specific mortality
risk using data from the Georgia Cancer Registry in the US.
And they found positive associations among non-Hispanic White women,
but not among Black women.
This study, published last year in "Cancer Medicine," examined mortality
rates from all cancers from the Pennsylvania Cancer
Registry in the US
in relation to different geospatial neighborhood-level trauma measures
created using data such as on violent crimes and mental health.
And they found that neighborhoods with high cancer mortality were more
likely to have relatively higher levels of trauma and lower
prevalence of cancer prevention behavior, such as maintaining a healthy weight.
And this study, published last year in "JAMA Network Open,"
aimed to validate that higher neighborhood socioeconomic
status using the census tract at diagnosis
linked with the Yoast index, which is created using several American
Community Survey variables such as rent and home value, was
associated with lower incidence of triple-negative breast cancer among
Black women using SEER Cancer Registries.
And this choropleth map shown on the right here nicely
cross-classified counties in the US with both higher cancer
incidence and higher poverty in darker
colors.This study,
also published last year in JAMA Network Open, looked at
county-level cancer screening, cancer prevalence, and
cancer mortality rates for breast, lung, prostate, and colon
cancers using Medicare and federal data in the US and determined
their association with various geospatial community-level measures listed here,
including on lifestyle. And one of the findings from this study
showing that the smoking rate was the most important factor in
explaining geographic variation in lung and
colorectal cancer mortality,
and these maps here showing the least favorable combination of
factors, so representing areas with higher smoking
prevalence and higher cancer mortality.
This study, published this year,
examined neighborhood exposome factors from sources including CDC
Places in relation to survival among women
diagnosed with breast cancer in Virginia in the US, showing
associations with housing cost, residential mobility, and
household crowding operating at different geographic scales.
So some based on the census tract at diagnosis and some based on
buffers created around geocoded addresses at the time of diagnosis.
And in our study entitled "Agricultural Glyphosate Use and Early
Onset Colorectal Cancer Mortality," supported by the Dillon Family Foundation,
which will be presented by Jia Yu Chloe Lin at the ACR poster session this
Tuesday,
we linked geospatial data on agricultural glyphosate
pesticide applications with all death certificates in the
US from 1989 to 2023 using the county of
residence at death. And we found that residents
in areas with higher glyphosate use is associated with a
16% increased risk for colorectal cancer-specific
mortality among those less than 50 years old, which is higher than
the 11% increased risk among those 50 and older.
And I also wanted to mention that existing cohort
studies, cancer registries may have participant
address information baseline, or even better, updated over time,
available for linkage with geospatial data.
Yet participants can move over time, called residential
mobility, and thus their exposures may change.
So to help fill in the gaps, whether before baseline
or even in between time points when longitudinal data were
collected, commercial address data, such as from LexisNexis,
which scrapes data from public records like credit reports, can
facilitate reconstruction of detailed residential address histories
described in this paper published this year in JESSI,
where information like name and phone number from
sister study cohort participants were sent to LexisNexis, and
then what was sent back were addresses and time points to create
residential address histories, which is really critical to really
meaningfully interrogate this exposome aspect of exposures
occurring over one's life course.
And to show you the different types of geospatial environment and
cancer epidemiology work that has been recently funded
to our lab at the Fred Hutch Cancer Center.
So we were awarded a grant from the American Cancer Society to
examine solar jet lag, which is a source
of environmental circadian misalignment due to differential
light exposure based on time zone position.
It's using our new geospatial model, developed using geospatial data
from Google Earth Engine and other sources, validated using wearable light sensors.
And this model will be linked with geocoded residential address history, so where
people have moved over time, of US veterans to examine
hepatocellular carcinoma or HCC risk using electronic health
records. We were also awarded an NIH
R21 grant last year. This is funded by NIHS but
administered by NHLBI to examine sleep health
outcomes using surveys from over 24,000 adults
across the US. We will be linking their geocoded
addresses with geospatial data on different environmental exposures,
including our new geospatial solar jet lag model.
And sleep disruption is one of the pathways through which solar jet
lag is purported to impact cancer risk.
And we were recommended for funding for a new Department of War,
formerly Department of Defense, Peer Reviewed Cancer Research Program
Impact Award.
We will be linking military deployment locations with geospatial
data on air pollution, dust storms, sandstorms to
examine in relation to HCC risk among US
veterans. And this builds on our lab's prior work demonstrating a
positive association with residential, so not deployment, but residential air
pollution exposure.
Now next, recent studies have also used geospatial science to answer
questions regarding, is climate change associated with cancer?
For example, alongside Dr. Jamie Hart, our next speaker, we published a paper
last year looking at outdoor air pollution, wildfires, and cancer
survival. We used geospatial satellite-based particulate
matter less than 2.5 microns in diameter, or PM2.5 air pollution
exposure data, combined with satellite-based data on wildfire
locations and linked these data with information from
over seven million cancer patients from SEER Cancer
Registries. And we observed that among cancer
patients, higher PM2.5 exposure was associated with an increased
risk for death due to cancer among those living in areas more
heavily impacted by wildfires.
And in this study that was published this year in Science Advances,
mortality data from the CDC in the US were linked
with geospatial data on wildfire smoke-specific
PM2.5 air pollution. And the authors found that a
0.1 microgram per cubic meter increase in wildfire smoke
PM2.5 levels was associated with about 490
deaths from cancer per year.And in
addition to climate change-driven environmental
exposures, I wanted to highlight how research also
examines climate change-related disruptions in cancer
care delivery. This review, published last year, identified over 30 studies
discussing issues like transportation challenges and power supply outages
that can have population-level impacts on screening and
treatment.
And in this study that was published last year in "Cancer Causes and Control,"
lung, breast, colorectal, and prostate cancer prevalence data from
Medicare in the US were linked with county-level Federal
Emergency Management Agency, or FEMA, National Risk Index
data, which encompasses hazards like hurricanes and
wildfires, to identify geographic
areas of vulnerability. So with co-occurring high
cancer prevalence and high exposure to natural hazards,
shown in red in these maps.
And recent studies have also addressed how we can integrate
internal exposome measures, such as using geospatial science,
with internal exposome measures, such as using omics to study health.
In this study, for example, published last year in "Nature Medicine,"
using UK Biobank data, the researchers quantified
the relative contributions of the exposome and
genomics in aging and premature mortality.
And the exposome was measured using geocoded residential
addresses linked with geospatial datasets on green space and
blue space and others. And then genomics was assessed using polygenic
risk scores. And they found that the exposome explained
most of the variation in lung cancer mortality, shown in teal in this
figure, while breast and prostate cancer mortality were more
influenced by genetics, shown in yellow.
Now finally, how is geospatial science being utilized
to translate findings from epidemiology to improve
population health?
In this study published last year among lung carcinoma patients
from the Massachusetts Cancer Registry in the US, zip codes
at diagnosis were linked with geospatial data from the census.
And with this study observing that education in the top
map and income in the bottom map were
associated with late to early-stage prevalence ratios for lung
cancer, which the researchers hope to inform locations for
early intervention efforts, including patient provider education and
mobile lung cancer screening clinics.
And another translational example is one of our lab's projects,
which is a new interactive geospatial web app called
GeoExMap, or the Geospatial Exposome Map, that our lab launched last
week at the ASPO conference in Denver.
This is accessible through the QR code shown here, which takes you straight to
geoexmap.fredhutch.org. Two years in the making, funded by
the Dillon Family Foundation. So this new geospatial web app is open
source. It was created to support the Fred Hutch Cancer Center Office of
Community Outreach and Engagement in their work to reduce cancer
disparities in Washington state in the US, which is the catchment
area for the Fred Hutch Cancer Center.
And this web app enables mapping and downloading of
neighborhood-level geospatial data on over 175, and
counting, health and environmental variables.
And the variables that we included were determined based on
existing scientific evidence, based on our own research,
but most importantly, through a community-engaged approach.
So we incorporated very valuable input from all three Fred Hutch
community advisory boards. And to promote disease
prevention and control efforts, GeoExMap includes
practical and actionable health and prevention tips for every single
variable in the app. So for example, when you map radon, you can click
on the tips button and you can see strategies for exposure mitigation, like
where to get free radon test kits to lower your lung cancer risk.
When you map the different social determinants of health variables in GeoExMap, you
can click on the tips button and it'll take you to resources for social
services, like how to apply for food assistance in Washington state, how to
apply for Medicaid. And I'm very proud of this work.
I'm committed to enhancing its utility, reach, and impact
in improving community health and wellbeing.
And another translational project from our lab, also funded by the Dillon
Family Foundation, was an electronic health record data-driven public
health intervention using geospatial data,
where we contacted over 64,000 patients in
Washington state at high risk for air pollution-related health
effects during wildfire season last year.
And we linked patient zip codes in the Epic electronic health
record with geospatial data on PM2.5 air
pollution levels to identify patients residing in
high-exposure areas. We then sent these patients outreach
through email, through SMS text message, and also through MyChart
patient portal messages with a link to visit an education
website that we designed with evidence-based air pollution
exposure mitigation strategies.
For example, how to use the air quality index, how to build your own
portable air cleaner. And we also provided the patients with information on how to
schedule a same-day virtual PCP appointment at UW Medicine or University
of Washington Medicine. And we observed very favorable levels of
engagement and healthcare services utilization.
So we reached over 12,000 patients.
Over 4,000 patients scheduled appointments with PCPs.
And this approach could absolutely be scaled to
target other populations in the context of cancer to
empower high-risk patients with information to help protect
themselves from environmental hazards.So in
summary, geospatial methods and technologies can
really substantively enhance cancer population sciences research,
as evidenced by the continuous growth of publications over the past several
decades. And geospatial data, they are widely available
at this point, like available through application processes in existing
cohorts, cancer registries. Also, these data are
often publicly available from federal agencies and other sources.
And there is a wide breadth of research being conducted, touching
on many different outcomes across the cancer continuum shown
today, from instance to survival, from screening and
prevention to healthcare access.
And some studies addressing brand new questions and some
studies addressing old questions, but using newer data sets
and other time periods, so still very meaningful work.
And importantly, the ability to incorporate internal
exposome measures can meaningfully extend research
questions beyond geospatial measures to consider biology.
And I wanted to say that key considerations based on the topics covered
today are that it is important to think about which of
the many different geospatial measures out there will be most relevant to your
research. I would, of course, recommend considering what's been examined in
prior research, determining if some measure is more
plausibly associated with your outcome, perhaps based on the input
data that's used for the construction of that measure.
And also conducting sensitivity analyses using multiple measures, comparing and
contrasting your results. Also, having a good understanding of
resolution and extent on the spatial and temporal
scales of the various geospatial data in your projects.
That is absolutely critical. Can you access or generate
residential address histories? Not just baseline, not just a diagnosis.
This will inform if you can consider life course exposures, timing
of exposures, exposures during relevant and critical time periods or windows of
exposure, and also exposure lags to take into account
latency periods in cancer studies.
And then also if there are spatial and temporal
mismatches in your data that you need to reconcile.
Another important consideration is exposure mixtures.
We are exposed to a multitude of environmental exposures in our
lives, and there are advanced mixture modeling methods,
one listed here, that enable the assessment of the
independent and aggregate effects of environmental exposures
on health. And I would recommend being forward-thinking
in how to translate epidemiologic studies on
etiology towards population health impact, getting knowledge
gained from your research into the hands of people who will benefit from
it the most. It is a solutions-oriented frame of thinking that I have
challenged myself with, that I have challenged my lab with, with several of our
translational projects showcased today.
And finally, I would like to end on what I think is something to watch out for.
So in 2025, Google launched geospatial
reasoning, or generative AI for geospatial
problem-solving. Gemini, which is Google's large language
model, will orchestrate inference and analysis
across Google's foundation models, across Google's geospatial data
sets, and importantly, across your own geospatial data that you can
upload. And your geospatial workflows will be conducted
on Google Cloud.
You'll be able to generate rapid insights and data visualizations,
and anyone who's experienced in geospatial analyses knows that computing
time, computing power can be a huge bottleneck.
So I will be really excited to see how this can be deployed in
geospatial work moving forward. This technology, it's still in the testing
phase, but you can sign up for their updates on their
website. And I would like to thank my wonderful collaborators.
I would like to acknowledge support from our funding sponsors, and thank you so
much. I will hand it over to Dr. Jamie Hart.
Okay. I'd like to thank the organizers for the invitation.
Anytime you have a rockstar trainee like Trang, you say yes to be in any
format with her. So she's one of the few people that always get to yes.
I think you might be one of the, like one or two.
So I'm gonna take off from where Trang led us, and I'm gonna talk specifically
about the impacts of the environmental exposures that she highlighted
on your cancer risk and survival.
I have nothing to disclose.
And so what we'll be talking through today is sort of a quick primer on the health
effects of two examples of the natural and built environment.
We'll talk a little bit about the biological plausibility about the effects of the
environment on both cancer incidence and cancer survival outcomes.
Trang kind of kicked this off for me, but we'll talk about new and exciting
research utilizing cancer registry data.
We'll highlight some translational and community engagement strategies that I think
are definitely emerging and should be pushed further.
We'll talk about future directions, and then we'll conclude.
So in terms of the health effects, the OG
of the environmental research is air pollution.
It's actually where I started my work.
It's definitely where the biggest bulk of the literature comes from.
It also set the table in terms of a lot of ways of how to think about
doing environmental exposures. So air pollution was kind of the
natural growth of looking at the health effects of smoking, so we
stepped down to air pollution, but a lot of the framework that was developed in air
pollution is used very broadly in terms of environmental exposures.
So 13 years ago, which feels like five minutes ago in
terms of this research, IARC, the International Agency of Research on
Cancer, declared air pollution a carcinogen.
Now, at the time, everybody was a little surprised that they went
that far because the evidence at that point was really only
there for lung cancer and particulate matter air pollution, specifically
PM2.5, or the particulate matter less than 2.5 microns in
diameter.So
if you want to read IARC's report, which is a really beautifully written report on
the state of the epidemiology, the toxicology, and the exposure evidence at that
time in 2013, that's the QR code below that chunk of text.
And what they had to work with for the epi side is somewhat
illustrated on the graphic here. What you're seeing is that this is a
forest plot of all of the different studies, some of which were actually available
after IARC. You can see some of the publication dates.
In the first column are all the studies from North America, and the studies on the
right are from the rest of the world, and the QR code there will take you to
that paper by Michelle Turner that has that evidence.
This is a paper from 2021, so there's actually even
more now. And what you'll see in this is that
there's different... Yeah, you can actually see that.
So the black circles are for each group of studies because people have
reanalyzed their data multiple times as more data have come in.
When you see down at the bottom selected studies, it's the black dots for each
series. So a lot of these came out of the department at the Harvard School of
Public Health, like the Harvard Six City study.
My thesis is in there, which always makes me feel proud when I see that in the
IARC decision. But overall, when you look at about a
10 microgram per meter cubed increase in PM2.5,
you see about a 13% increased risk of incidence of lung
cancer, and that's pretty consistent around the world.
The European studies are a little stronger than those from the US.
But even as there's probably another 20 or so papers,
especially the papers from Asia are really filling in.
You see this really consistent evidence around the world.
So again, this evidence of declaring
air pollution a carcinogen seems to be really robust, but really, really
was only developed on the lung cancer.
In that report that IARC put out, they talked about, well, there's some emerging
evidence for breast cancer, there's some emerging evidence for bladder cancer.
But at the time, the lung cancer evidence was really the strongest.
So that's kind of where we started.
So in the 13 years since then, not surprisingly, there's been more research.
And a lot of the expansion has been in different cancers.
So again, I hinted that IARC had mentioned breast cancer as one of
the kind of speculative research areas.
This has really broadened out, but I think it's been an interesting story.
So this is a recent paper. Lexy White, who's an intramural
researcher at NIEHS, put together a consortium of
five of the largest prospective cohorts of women in the
US and did a large analysis of air pollution and breast cancer
risk. So again, a lot of these studies had done their own stuff,
slightly underpowered in a lot of cases, even for breast cancer.
But what she saw was that when you put together all the data from all the cohorts,
what you saw, this panel, Panel A, is the associations with
NO2, or nitrogen dioxide, which is more of a measure of traffic.
It comes from a lot of car exhaust. And on the right-hand side is the PM2.5
estimates. And so what you see is that in the overall,
when you look at all the cohorts, you do see a suggestive elevated risk of
breast cancer, which is mostly being driven by premenopausal breast cancer
and breast cancer among Black women and non-Hispanic White women.
And again, confidence intervals are pretty broad on this, even putting together
five cohorts worth of data.
But for PM2.5, she didn't really see anything.
So again, that PM2.5 story is really strong for lung cancer,
but for breast cancer, not as strong. We're seeing it more with NO2.
And this has been pretty consistent across the literature that breast cancer seems
to be tracking more with that traffic-related air pollution than with
PM2.5. So again,
air pollution is a heterogeneous mixture of different things, and depending on the
studies and the different levels of exposure that you're looking at around the
world, we're seeing different patterns with incidence and across the different
cancers.
Where the research is moving, Trang kind of hinted at this in her earlier talk, is
that newer work is really focused on those sources or
specific sources of air pollution or specific pollutants.
So, looking at her work, looking at wildfire
exposure, looking at different components of PM2.5, so the
metal levels in PM2.5, looking at things like
dioxin or different hazardous air pollutants.
Again, that's really where the research is going to try and give us more of a sense
of where or which types of sources are driving different
independent cancers. The research is also moving really quickly in survival.
So again, all of the evidence from maybe 10 years ago was pretty much
only on incidence, maybe some mortality studies.
But now really focusing in on those survivor populations and trying to
ascertain if they are more or less vulnerable to the aspects of air pollution.
So, as Trang mentioned, she did this really elegant analysis looking at air
pollution and wildfires using SEER Medicare data.
So again, looking in the different SEER counties, looking at both air pollution and
where that air pollution was coming a lot from different wildfire
exposures. And again, showing that even for the same
increase in air pollution exposure for PM2.5, if that
PM2.5 was coming more from wildfires than not, you saw
elevated risk. So again, suggesting that that wildfire PM may
be more toxic for cancer outcomes
than other sources of PM2.5. So again, if you're thinking with your
regulatory hat on, then you may be wanting to go
after wildfires more than you go after other sources of
PM2.5, or maybe not go after anything these days.
So trying to move-- After you study air pollution for about 10 years, you really
just want to look at something that's good for you in the environment because air
pollution is associated with just about everything we look at.
So, right about 10 years ago, we as a group, and pretty much the
literature as a whole, started really looking at nature exposure as a
beneficial aspect of the environment that we hope to quantify the effects
of. So greenness, as is the most common
environmental way of looking at nature, has often been characterized
using this measure called the Normalized Difference Vegetation Index, or
NDVIPartially because this is available
worldwide every 16 days at a 30-meter
resolution since the 1980s as part of a satellite called
Landsat. It's freely available. Used to be that it would take
approximately six months to download a year's worth of data at 16
days in a 30-meter scale.
Now, thanks to Google Earth Engine, it takes about a day and a half.
So my trainees are much happier to spend time doing their analyses than downloading
data for months and months. So this map just gives you a sense of what greenness
looks like. This is July of 2000.
The Northeast
and the eastern half of the United States has more of this than the
western half, but again, 30-meter resolution, you can get down to a pretty small
scale.
So how is NDVI calculated? It's clearly an index, so there's going to be a
ratio involved. And so what it is, is we're using satellite data
using two different wavelengths.
And what this gives you a measure of is actually the photosynthetic activity in
that 30-meter pixel. So if you look at this graphic from NASA,
you have two trees, and you're looking at the ratio of the near-infrared
band and the visible band, and what you can see is that the
tree on the left is healthier than the tree on the right, and so it has a higher
NDVI for that specific tree. On the right is a graphic actually from
a company that will offer to fly over your crops.
So this measure was actually originally developed by USDA as a measure of crop
health.
And what they'll do is they'll fly over your crops, and so they're giving you an
estimate of what this looks like. So if you have zero for your
NDVI, it's either bare ground or dead plants.
So no photosynthetic activity. So it could be just the winter.
If you have a measure of one, it means in that pixel that you're measuring, it is
fully covered in highly photosynthetically active material.
Now, again, this doesn't tell you anything about the aesthetics of that.
It could be a weedy, overgrown lot that just has a lot of green grass or a
beautifully landscaped, manicured garden or something.
So again, this is really just pure photosynthetic activity is what we're
measuring. So there was a recent article, actually now
2023, that came out trying to look at what was the
state of the literature on NDVI and cancer
incidence specifically. So you can see here grouped by the different cancer
types, what the state of the literature was three years ago.
And it's heterogeneous. So what you can see is for things like prostate
cancer, lung cancer, you see that there
do appear to be beneficial effects of greenness on cancer
incidence, but that there's a lot of heterogeneity both across
cancer site and within cancer site.
And you can see that there's research here from
mainly France, Israel, China, and the US,
and that actually the whole bottom section of this graph is coming from a single
study in China. So again, we're not seeing consistent
results here for any given cancer or any given place in the
world. Now, I'll say in the last three years,
most of the papers that have been published have been showing beneficial effects.
But again, there's a lot of heterogeneity, partially because NDVI just
means photosynthetic activity, right?
It may not mean that it's--
A lot of the hypothesized mechanisms are that it increases physical activity,
it reduces overall stress levels.
Again, those have different associations with different cancer sites.
But again, like everything else, these measures of how we think about the
built environment are evolving rapidly.
So emerging research that has come out in probably the last maybe three to five
years, maybe one to five, is using images of locations.
So instead of using satellite data coming down from thousands of feet
above your house, we can use things like Google Street View or
other street-level imagery to be able to quantify measures of the built
environment. So for example, this is the Google Street View image outside of the
convention center. You can see a lot of hardscape, some plants,
some trees, but in general, not a lot of green space, not a lot of
photosynthetic activity going on right outside the building.
Now, what you can do with this is you can couple these images with machine
learning algorithms that have been developed for lots of different purposes, and
you can actually quantify the amount of different classes
of information. So for example, what you're seeing in this image as
it's going through London is you can see that you can quantify pixels as
if, are they road? Are they humans? Are they cars? Are they trees?
And so again, instead of just being able to say, "Here's the amount of
photosynthetic activity in a 30-meter pixel," we can actually quantify,
are there trees? Are there grasses? Are there plants?
Are there agricultural lands that may be having pesticides applied to them?
We can identify street features like bike lanes or sidewalks that may
help with increasing physical activity in different areas.
If we're interested in exposures among older individuals, we can look for things
like street furniture that may encourage them to go outside and interact with their
neighborhoods and their neighbors.
We can identify things like infrastructure, so things like bus shelters, all
kinds of different things that maybe tell us about different environmental factors
in the environment.
Also, it just looks really cool to be able to show this graphic where it's in
real-time making all the pixels colored.
So what does this look like if you're doing this for-- We're doing it for--
Apparently, my colleague Peter James just finished a project where he
classified
about 350 million images for the entire US
across a 20-year spatial scale. So you have
multiple images across time.
And what you can do, again, is you run one of these AI machine learning
algorithms on this, and you can classify all the pixels.
So Google Street View takes four images off the top of the camera,
so you get the whole 360-degree rotation.
And what you can do is you can quantify the images.
So these images here
have approximately 23% trees
andDown, shift it down a little bit, and 22% road,
and 13% grass. So again, you can take this and you can assign, if somebody
was living right next to this image, you can assign them that
information instead of just saying they have an NDVI of 6.6, right?
So now we're able to distinguish the beneficial effects of trees versus plants
versus greenness. And in a lot of our initial work, we're actually seeing that
contrary to the NDVI, we only see benefits from trees.
We're not really seeing benefits from other plants or grasses, and in some cases,
grasses are harmful. So we're trying to figure out if that's because grasses are an
indication of sprawl,
if they're an indication of the lawn chemicals that we like to put on our lawns.
But we're still trying to figure out what's wrong with the grass.
Which is interesting because city planners, when they heard increased NDVI,
heard increased grass, because it's the cheapest way to get a lot of photosynthetic
activity.
So what are the mechanisms that underlie this?
So again, that paper by Michelle Turner and colleagues had a really brilliant
summary of the mechanistic data for air pollution.
And again, it's broad. So air pollution particles can actually
translocate across your lungs, get into your circulation, and deposit in
every tissue in your body. They actually can go up your
nasal pathway and reach your brain directly, so they can cross the blood-brain
barrier. So they can have local effects where they can cause
things. But broadly, they have a lot of oxidative damage and cause low-grade
chronic inflammation and have substantial molecular changes.
So everything from DNA adducts to direct DNA damage to
changes in the epigenome.
So again, you can see how all these pathways could be influencing things all the
way from initiation through progression of cancer.
So how can you use... One of the really active areas
in the environmental epidemiology of cancer is using
cancer registry data. So first is that Trang
talked about how you first need to geolocate a person.
So, cancer registries often have
patient address at diagnosis. But it's really complicated to get that data.
So depending on the registry, the state laws, privacy concerns,
a lot of registries can't give you that data.
So doing our traditional processes of getting data, geocoding
it, and appending hundreds of different spatial and environmental exposures,
you can't really do that with a lot of cancer registry data.
So actually, one of my former trainees, Harer and Iona, have this really great
paper talking about some processes that are more
amenable to... Because a lot of times what we would do if we
were working with another cohort, we'd say, "Okay, here are our terabytes of
environmental exposure data and some R code.
Use that or use another GIS platform to append these exposures." A lot of
cancer registries don't have that kind of expertise to be able to do that or the
bandwidth computationally to be able to do that.
So again, in this paper, they describe a process by which you can actually get
around some of those limitations to actually append these data, which has been
revolutionary in terms of being able to look at general population samples.
So, a recent paper that came out looking at green space
in the SEER data from the whole US found
that looking at mortality among individuals in these
registries, that prostate cancer deaths, overall deaths, and
cardiovascular disease deaths were all reduced in patients who
lived in areas with increasing levels of greenness.
In
using cancer registry data from Kentucky, these researchers looked at
hotspots for both breast cancer and colorectal cancer and looked to
see if those hotspots were associated with increases in
airborne levels of a number of different heavy metals.
So they identified hotspots in Kentucky broadly for these using
geospatial methods. And then they overlaid this information
from the EPA on different levels of things like arsenic,
cadmium,
nickel, and hexachrome, I never say this word right,
chromium
and basically identified that a number of the hotspots in Kentucky were being
driven by exposures to these metals.
Trang's paper looking at wildfires, again, looked at air pollution from a
specific source and found that that was elevated.
And again,
being able to look at this registry data gives us a more representative
look than some of the cancer cohorts that, in some cases, have less
representative populations, especially by race and ethnicity and socioeconomic
status.
So when we think about the translational and community engagement pieces of how do
you translate this work, Trang's done some brilliant work that I think is leading
the field in ways to do this in a way that both engages the community and
provides relevant educational opportunities.
So I think one of the things that is moving forward the most is
clinician and patient education.
So again, even something as simple as helping cancer patients
understand that when the weather
forecast on your news talks about air pollution alerts for sensitive
populations, understanding that they are one of those sensitive populations,
right? And maybe should limit their outdoor activities for a few days during
heavy pollution events.
Again, giving patients tips to be able to avoid air pollution and enhance
their greenness exposures in other things, right?
Again, being able to enable people.
I think one of the strongest things we can all do is advocate for environmental
laws and enforcement. A lot of these problems are tackled at the
city, state, and federal levels, and if we put pressure on
our politicians and our
service leaders to actually enforce the laws that we have and to
press the laws that we need, again, that's going to do the biggest bang
for our buck instead of trying to put it on the patients themselves.
The patients have a really hard time reducing their air pollution levels.
The government is much more effective at that.
And lastly,
a lot of the science is moving toward intervention.
So everything from doing trials where we give cancer
patients air pollutionReducing equipment for their
house and see if that helps with their survival outcomes, to
again, seeing if things like population level
education processes can help with this.
So really working with communities to know what they're the most
concerned about, help
provide them with the power and the tools to fight on their own
behalfs, and also just give people education so that they can do
kind of common sense things when the government can't do it for us.
So in terms of future directions, I think advances in geospatial measures are
happening all the time. So everything from AI and machine learning to help improve
all of our different exposure models, enhance satellite data,
that we were even just five years ago using
250-meter pixel data for greenness, now we're down to 30 meters.
There's actually products that you can get down to submicron levels.
It just costs a lot of money to use them.
The Street View imagery I think is really cool because it's available not only in
the US but around the world, and so being able to help us
expand the research in this field past the US and Europe.
Really an increased focus on survival and survival populations, the bulk of the
literature is on incidents, but I think that's moving really quickly.
Figuring out the impact of interventions to reduce exposures, really
broadening the diversity of the populations that we're studying.
Both Trang and Iona have great populations that are leading a lot of this
work. And also moving out of the US and Europe as
the primary sources of all of this.
There's a lot of research coming out in Asia in emerging literature in
LMICs to be able to figure out how we can broaden the research around the world.
So in conclusion, the places where we live, work, and play influence our risk of
cancer and post-diagnostic outcomes.
There are robust biological mechanisms that underlie all of this.
When I first started, we used to be like, "Really?
The environment can't do anything for cancer.
It's all genetic."
That story has changed, thankfully.
I think cancer registry data are, to date, an underutilized resource.
Clinicians in the community can be powerful advocates for strong environmental
protections. And frankly, this is a
very exciting area of research. Again, from 10 years ago, where
we wouldn't have gotten this many people in a room to talk about environment,
it's really nice to actually see that people are coming along with us these days.
So I just want to thank the Spatial and Contextual Exposomics in Epidemiology, or
SPACe, Lab. If you want to follow the work of our lab, you can take a
picture of this QR code. If you want to send me an email, the trick of it
is you just got to spell my first name correctly, and then you can get an email to
me. So, with that, I will pass it on to Iona.
Nice job.
Thank you so much. Those are really hard acts to follow, but I will try my best.
It's an honor to be here today. My name is Iona Cheng, and I will
give us our next
presentation.
We have 20 minutes.
Okay.
On the impact of structural and social drivers of health on cancer risk and
survival.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So for today, I'm going to focus on five main topics.
I'll start with a really brief introduction in regards to structural and social
drivers of health, which has already been touched upon, and then share some
examples of the applications of investigating structural and social
drivers of health in cancer research.
Also touch upon biological plausibility in the pathways and how we're trying to
explore and address questions in terms of how structural and social drivers may
get under the skin.
Also touch upon translational and community impact, and just end on some future
directions.
So just to set the stage, which I think we're all very well familiar because this
is a topic of interest and we're all here today, in terms
of how we consider social drivers of health as the conditions in which people
are born, grow, work, live, and age.
And here you can see these outlined as the living conditions, capturing the
physical environment, such as land use and transportation, the
economic environment, employment and income, for example, the
service environment, such as healthcare and education, and the social
environment, such as violence and culture.
And we recognize that the structural drivers of
health are the wider set of forces and systems
shaping these conditions of daily life, right?
So we think of these as the utmost upstream contributing
factors. We think about the various practices and
policies, such as structural racism, all the various isms
that create inequities in terms of how the distribution of resources
occur that shape the living conditions.
And it's the combination of these continuums of interactions
between both these structural and social drivers that influence health
behaviors and ultimately shape downstream effects on health
outcomes.
So this is one conceptual model that we often turn to as we try to
address questions in regards to cancer disparities and cancer
outcomes. This framework was actually put forth many years ago by the
Centers of Population Health and Health Disparities, recognizing
the fundamental causes of cancer disparities,
sourcing from the structural context in regards to structural racism,
segregation of policies, the contribution of the institutional
context, and how you think about that shapes the various attributes
of both the social and physical context of where people live.
So we touched upon many of these measures in the earlier talks.
We know that in combination with sociodemographic factors and how that
shapes individual behaviors such as smoking,
diet, and obesity, are key factors that contribute to cancer
disparities, and ultimately the biological response of all of these
upstreamand individual factors and how
they shape, ultimately, cancer disparities.
And we know that there's interaction that occurs across multiple of
these levels as they ultimately influence cancer outcomes.
So now just to illustrate a couple of examples in looking at structural and social
drivers of health and cancer research.
So the first example I wanted to walk through is work that's being done,
led by Dr. Chris Hyman at USC. This is a very large initiative called
the RESPOND Study that's focused on studying prostate cancer in
African American Black men with an emphasis on addressing the role
of social stressors, genetics, tumor genomics, and
biology.
Project one of this large U19 initiative, led by Dr.
Scarlett Link-Gomez, is looking at the associations between neighborhood
social stressors and risk of aggressive prostate cancer mortality among
African American and White men. And this is a study that's
leveraging the cancer registry data
that's been geocoded, which we've heard some examples of that processes,
appended to various geospatial data.
And it includes 10 cancer registries across eight states
for which this RESPOND cohort was derived, including California,
the Detroit metropolitan area, Florida, Georgia, Louisiana, New Jersey,
New York, and Texas.
And so within this study,
we are focused on several structural and social drivers derived
from geospatial data. One of that is a measure of housing
discrimination, a redlining index that I'm going to speak a little bit more in
detail about.
Also, a measure of racial ethnic segregation.
This was developed by Joe Gimbel looking at neighborhood typologies in
regards to racial and ethnic composition
and various social environment factors, including crime and socioeconomic
status, built environment factors such as walkability and the
food environment. And we know that each of these
different measures of social drivers and structural drivers capture different
elements that influence cancer outcomes.
So now just to walk you a little bit more specifically on this measure of a
redlining index, and this was developed by Kirsten Beyer at the Medical College of
Wisconsin.
And this is using contemporary Home Mortgage Disclosure Act data
in which we calculate the odds ratios of being denied a mortgage
application in a local area. And here we're considering a census tract as
our neighborhood unit compared to a larger region, so an MSA.
And when there's an odds ratio of one or less, we consider this no
difference or a lower likelihood in a mortgage denial in a neighborhood
than an MSA. And then when we see an odds ratio greater than one, this is
indicative of a higher likelihood of a mortgage denial in the neighborhood than of
the MSA.
So now to show you the distribution of this redlining
index for Black and non-Hispanic White men with prostate cancer,
cases that were diagnosed from 2006 through 2013
across the eight states and 10 registries.
And you can see we have a very large sample size of Black men of over 82,000
men and non-Hispanic Whites of over 314,000.
So really leveraging the large population-based sample occurring in
the cancer registry. And so for this figure, this is showing you for
several states, the first one being California, the proportion
of
non-Hispanic White men and Black men residing in neighborhoods that are
considered redlined. And for example, I think probably one of the most
prominent
states to illustrate
is in Detroit. So these are non-Hispanic White men, and you can see here
this darker blue. So this is having an odds ratio of less than one or
equal to one
of residing in an area that's been denied a mortgage
rate within a census tract. And you can
see
here, this is probably maybe about 70% who live in an
area that has not been redlined, in contrast to about 30%
in these lighter blue colors, indicating a redlined area.
In comparison to African American men with prostate cancer, look at the
distribution of where they reside in regards to redlined neighborhoods.
We can see at the highest level of an odds ratio of three or greater of being
denied a mortgage application. This is over,
potentially, almost 60% in Detroit live in those
neighborhoods. And overall in RESPOND, we see
this distribution for non-Hispanic White men with prostate cancer.
Roughly 40% live in redlined neighborhoods.
And in comparison to Black men,
we can see this is probably almost 70%.
So really demonstrating the pervasiveness of this inequity in terms of residents in
redlined areas.
So here we wanted to look at the association between a joint variable of race
and redlining. So to orient you,
here on the x-axis, the reference groups are
non-Hispanic White men with prostate cancer who live in
either a low or non-redline or low likelihood neighborhood,
in comparison to non-Hispanic White men at higher levels,
and then also for Black men residing in no redlined or
less likelihood
and then increasing levels of redlining.
And so you can see this general pattern in terms of having an increased hazard
ratio for prostate cancer mortality in comparison to non-Hispanic White
men
living in these non-redlined neighborhoods of increasing
mortality due to prostate cancer.
Actually, in California, there are no men who actually live in the highest redlined
areas. And then for Black men with prostate cancer, you can see
this progressive increase in the hazard ratio for prostate cancer
mortality associated with residing in neighborhoods of increasing levels of
redlining.
A similar pattern is seen in Georgia and Louisiana.
You can see a little bit of range in the hazard ratio estimates.
Similarly, in Detroit, again, the hazard ratios are a bit lower there, but
New Jersey, it's quite striking, this pattern that we're seeing,
and a similar pattern in Texas and in
Florida.So we're seeing overall
here that higher prostate cancer mortality or lower
survival associated with living in neighborhoods with more
redlining for both Black and white men with prostate cancer.
Though we did observe higher hazard ratios among African American
men, just illustrating the disproportion and unequal disparity in
mortality.
So another
element I wanted to share about, which I see as an advancement in terms of us
thinking about structural drivers of health, is moving from a single
domain. So a lot of work has been focusing on housing
discrimination, such as redlining, to thinking about multi-domain measures of
structural racism. So we know that structural racism
operates through a system of mutually reinforcing institutions that
perpetuate health disparities through policy, practice, and norms.
And this is illustrated in a really nice study that was done in which they
looked at almost 33,000 individuals diagnosed with breast cancer from the
North Carolina Central Cancer Registry.
And here they created a composite index of structural racism at the county
level based on five domains. So this was the housing and physical
environment, education, employment, income, and health.
And what they found was for Black patients, for a 10-unit increase in
this composite index of structural racism, was associated with increased
odds of treatment delay. But among white patients, no
association was observed. So here we are seeing the differential
impact of structural racism across race.
And so within the multi-ethnic cohort, we are similarly thinking about this
consideration of a multi-domain measure of structural racism, and
so we're developing one that is racial and ethnic specific
for the various racial ethnic groups within the multi-ethnic cohort.
We're considering various measures and domains, including capturing
housing, education, employment, judicial system, and
unequal healthcare.
And just to illustrate, this is a preliminary dashboard where we are
showing you one of the components of structural racism.
So this is for Black or African American residents in California.
This is the LA region. And I'm just showing you one measure here.
This is home rentership.
And so what this
map has illustrated, and this is focused on a smaller area of a census-designated
place in comparison to a county,
where we've identified, for example, a region that is a
dark green. So there's no disparity in terms of Black or African
American residents in regards to home rentership in comparison to the
non-Hispanic white group.
Low disparity, which is indicated by the paler green regions
that you can see here, where there's low disparity in terms of home
rentership for Black or African American residents in comparison to the
non-Hispanic white group. And then quite pervasive, you can see across LA County
is a yellow, which is indicating high disparity between Black
or African American residents in comparison to non-Hispanic whites in regards
to home rentership. So we currently are conducting latent class
analysis to create this composite measure across these multiple
domains, and then we'll map that, and this will be a resource
for the community and for investigators to understand this composite
measure of structural racism that will be specific to each racial ethnic group.
Now to touch upon some of the biological pathways that we think about
when we're trying to answer questions about how structural and social drivers may
be operating, as was touched upon earlier.
So thinking about the internal exposome and how we can link that to
SSDH
measures and cancer outcomes. As was relayed earlier, we think about
the general external exposome. So these are the living
conditions such as climate, traffic, and then the
specific external exposome, thinking about individual
specific
risk factors and behaviors. And thinking through the internal exposome,
so these are the biological measures and processes, the omics,
in which may be impacted both by the general external exposome and
the specific external exposome.
And there's several frameworks that are put forth in trying to think about linking
structural and social drivers of health in terms of
its biological effects on health and cancer outcomes.
This is one that's commonly referred to in thinking about the social genomic
determinants of health. So these are defined as the physiological gene
regulatory pathways through which contextual factors, particularly one's
neighborhood, can affect the activity of the cancer genome and the surrounding
tumor microbiome to alter the disease progression and treat outcome.
And a really nice illustration of this was put forth in a report by Golla et al.,
offering a conceptual framework thinking about social signal transduction
and describing how the effects of objective and subjective neighborhood
disadvantage may lead to aggressive tumor biology.
And there's some really nice examples in the literature.
This was a report
recently that was looking at ambient outdoor heat.
So we're very interested about environmental stressors and
climate change as a social driver of health, and it's
associated with epigenetic aging, and this was using data from the Health
Retirement Study. So here they look at two measures of heat,
one that's categorized at a caution level that was 80 to 90 degrees
Fahrenheit, one at extreme caution, that's actually 92 to 103.
And just giving one example of looking at PhenoAge and one measure of
epigenetic aging, you can see looking
at these two heat indexes at the blood collection day, seven days
before, 30 days before blood collection, and 60 days, so thinking
about capturing short-term exposures to ambient outdoor heat, and then
also long-term exposures, looking at one year and six years prior to blood
collection. And seeing this pattern in terms of having
accelerated epigenetic age associated with both of these
index. And particularly in the long-term exposures, we can really
see the larger effect estimates associated with the extreme
caution level of outdoor ambient
heat.So we've also been interested in this question within the
Multi-Ethnic Cohort. So we've looked at neighborhood percent poverty.
This is a measure assessed 12 months before blood collection in
regards to epigenic aging
among Latinos in the California MEC.
And we've looked at various clocks, and I just illustrate a couple examples
where we are seeing suggestions of increased percent neighborhood poverty
associated with increased epigenetic aging.
Also, an epigenetic aging clock associated with telomere length,
particularly shorter telomere length indicating cellular aging.
So perhaps this could be a measure that could be considered in regards
to thinking about how a neighborhood measure could influence biology
and ultimately influence cancer outcomes.
Now to touch through some
discussion in regards to the translation of community impact of structural and
social drivers of health.
So,
having community advisory boards is just a vital component of the work that we've
been doing in terms of looking at structural drivers of health within our
studies. And we've been working with community advisory board members,
representing states from both the Multi-Ethnic Cohort, as
well as the Southern Community Cohort, so that's encompassing 14 states.
And our community advisory board members have really been exceptional
in terms of the emphasis for the work that we do
in terms of minimizing harm, avoiding reinforcing
misconceptions about structural and social drivers, improving the
relevance of our work and our measures by grounding them in terms of their
lived experiences, contextualizing our findings to
understand its impact, and then thinking through how do we share these results
for the best impact and reach to the community.
And then I wanted to share that the National Academy of Science of
Engineering and Medicine have
published this report, Integrating Social Care into Delivery of Healthcare:
Moving Upstream to Improve the Nation's Health.
And here they provide a framework emphasizing these
five elements of learning how the five As of social care can improve
overall health. So focusing on these five components of
awareness, adjustment, assistance, alignments, and
advocacy.
And in this report, they emphasize how healthcare can be aware of
the importance of social determinants of health, offer assistance, and make
adjustments for patients with social needs, and align with communities, and
advocate for policy change. And we see this work occurring through EHR
systems that are assessing social care and assessing resources.
For example, it could be in terms of food or transportation or housing.
And just to end on a couple thoughts in thinking about moving forward with this
work, I think just continual expansion in thinking about
the interactions that may be occurring across multiple structural and social
drivers of health. Further integration with biological measures such as
to stress and disease biomarkers, epigenetics, genetic stability,
somatic mutations, integrating with policy measures.
I would love to figure out how to develop a proposal also layering in
the influence of various policies such as smoking ordinances, fair
housing, healthcare,
which was touched upon earlier. Thinking of leveraging various data resources, so
we really can answer questions in terms of life course,
early life exposures, the important windows of susceptibility.
Often, most of our data focuses on residential information, so are there
ways that we can find to be able to assess neighborhood environments at both at
where we work and play?
Continual expansion of the multiple measures and
analytical tools that we use for this work,
as illustrated here, and then the continual building of community and policy
advocacy for translation.
So with that, I thank you,
and we'll open it up.
Okay.
All right. Thank you to our speakers.
So you can use the QR code to type in a question
from the comfort of your seat, and I will read the question, and then we can answer
it.
So we already have one question, actually.
Perhaps out of scope, but can you comment on connecting geospatial data
to cancer etiology, for example, mutation signatures?
I wonder if your social genomics
framework could speak to that.
So I think that is a question that we're very interested.
We do know we see in terms of individual risk factors, we know that there are
profiles and somatic mutations
linking to smoking behaviors. There has been work showing
relationships between air pollutant exposures,
and some somatic mutation, but there clearly is a large open field
in terms of the next set of type of research questions, really trying to
integrate
these geospatial measures and how they potentially could
shape various genomic signatures of somatic
alterations.
Thank you.
I had a few questions. So one was for Dr. Chang.
You
laid out those nice analyses using the redlining index, and I wondered
if you also looked at,
in addition to contemporary redlining, historical redlining, and if those results
track. And then my other question is for Dr. Hardt.
You spoke about some interventions, especially related to air
pollution. I'm not really up on the green space literature, but are there
the green prescriptions being implemented in
certain subgroups? Thanks.
So within the Response study, we haven't specifically looked at HLSC grades
in regards to
prostate cancer outcomes.
Scarlet, do you know if we've done other work in the cancer
registry?Yes, she's shaking her
head yes.
Sorry.
She's like, "Don't make me go to the mic."
Yeah, I won't get you to the mic. So there is work that's being done, not
specifically within Respond.
In process.
Oh, it's in process.
Oh, nice. Okay. Thanks.
Okay. Oh.
And in terms of the intervention, so if people haven't heard of green
prescriptions, it's mostly so far with children and
obesity, but it's where your prescriber
actually recommends that you spend more time in green areas and
increase your physical activity.
So I don't think that's really made it into the cancer field
yet. I think, again, because the literature's a little more nascent, but
again, there's so many benefits of greenness that even if it's for the mental
health part of dealing with the cancer diagnosis, I would say go
outside. There's a lot of hardscape outside, but there's some nice greenness in San
Diego, so at the end of the session, go frolic in the greenness.
Thank you. So we have four questions from online.
Oh, another one. Okay. The first one, can you touch on how to
link these resources, geospatial and others, to existing
cohorts? How would one go about starting?
So I could speak specifically to the Women's Health Initiative, for example.
There is a very nice website that you can go to where you can
propose, working on a paper or maybe conducting an ancillary
study. For example, if you might want to propose
linking
geo-coded address information of Women's Health Initiative or WHI
participants with new geospatial data sets, that's a possibility.
So go to the website. That's probably
the first step that I would recommend. Do you want to speak to Nurses and MEC?
Yeah. So I think for the Nurses' Health Studies and the Health Professionals
Follow-up Study, we've linked about
80 at this point, different geospatial measures.
So if we don't have it already, we're happy to work with people.
And again, we have a form on our website. It's nurseshealthstudies.org.
You go to the Researchers page, there's a simple little form you fill out, and then
you'll get in contact with us to work on those things.
And I would say most major cohorts, that's kind of the way you start it out is you
propose it, and then you spend a lot of time writing a data use agreement, but
otherwise, it's definitely
become a smoother process than it used to be.
That's correct. It's the same process for the Multi-Ethnic Cohort in terms of
putting in a data request for thinking about geospatial
neighborhood measures for your cancer question of interest.
Thank you. All right. Our next question, there are numerous
geospatial measures that can be used as a proxy exposome.
Which ones do you choose and why?
Oh, man.
So
yes, there are many data sets out there, and it
can be overwhelming. One of the first steps that I typically take is
to do a review of the literature, see what previous epidemiologic
studies have been using,
and then those particular, if it's an exposure model of
some geospatial exposure model of some
factor in the exposome, you can look at the methods paper and see if it's been
validated, if it's shown directions,
associations with outcomes in the direction that's expected.
Sometimes though, you will be limited, based on your study
population. You only have maybe locational information for your participants at
some particular point in time, so that kind of limits which geospatial data
set you can actually link appropriately with that
particular geospatial locational data.
But yes, that's usually my first step. What about you?
I trained you, so yeah.
You knew that part before you got to us, though.
Yeah, I think it's really looking at the spatial and temporal scales of the data
sets.
For example, for the air pollution world, we're always five years behind
in terms of waiting for a geospatial model.
So if I needed to map something to data for today, I have to wait about five years.
Or if I'm trying to use our cohort data back in the '80s, there's one
model that goes back that far. So we really didn't have to choose
very carefully because there was only one.
So I think that's really the way we often start out with is what's the highest
spatial and temporal resolution?
And then sometimes it's how easy or hard is it to actually access the model?
If it becomes a 72-year process of negotiations with a
group that has an exposure model, I'm probably not going to use it quite as often.
So it's a combination of ease of use and appropriateness of
use, I think.
And I think I'll just add, I think my approach has really been focused
on what your hypothesis is, right?
Mm-hmm.
So for your cancer site of interest,
do you think it'd be operating by what pathway, right? Is it an obesity pathway?
Is it a particular environmental exposure pathway?
What are the GIS resources that will help enable you to answer that question?
So you're right, there's a whole suite of measures, but I think it needs to
be grounded in thinking about what do you think are the pathways that are
specifically involved, so you can really develop your conceptual model and
framework to answer that research question.
I think for me, I started out, actually, I just did the math.
I think it was like 15 years ago, which at that time was considered novel, was
just the fact that, in that time in cancer epi, we all knew that you
needed to eat healthy, and you needed to exercise, and
just a simple question as if you live in a neighborhood that
allows that, right? And there was just becoming resources available to
look at GIS as regarding to neighborhood to ask that question, what about the
neighborhood? And
I got a lot of pushback because people thought it was just your behaviors, right?
This is just a proxy for your behavior. That is not it.
The neighborhood has its own independent effect than just health
behavior. It's not serving as a proxy.
There definitely is correlation, right? Because it's going through a process.
But we do see that the neighborhood itself has contributions.
So really thinking through what is that pathway that can influence your cancer
research question of interest.
These are good points. I'd add one last thing.
The distinction between investigator-initiated kind of exposure
models and then public source ones.
So when you spoke about, Jamie, the five-year lag that you have to wait,
is that Dr. Jeff Janosky's model?
Epi model.
There are more open source... Yeah.
There's an open source one that, it's just not as-
Yeah. So ones that I mentioned in my slide deck, for example, from
Washington University in St. Louis, and there's wildfire data out
of the Echo Lab in Stanford. So there's more and more
publicly available geospatial data sets out there that are validated that
are being used in many, many epi studies.
And that's, I think, kind of moving away from at least
several years, probably 10 years back, when you really had to link up through
a grant with an investigator so they would develop your model for that grant kind
of scenario.
Okay.
Have you seen or plan to work with ecological momentary
assessment to assign environmental exposures on the fly?
Yeah.
Yes. Not specifically for cancer outcomes, but
in the Nurses' Health Study we've been doing a
lot with mobile applications that allow us to track the
GPS coordinates of participants every 10 minutes for, we've so far run it up to a
year, and been able to push EMA questions to
ascertain, are you in a park? Are you
commuting in traffic? All kinds of different environmental exposures.
So being able to use that GPS location data to get beyond the residential address,
but also being able to ask participants about their exposures to a whole
host of different environmental exposures, including the food environment.
So asking people if they're near fast food establishments, at the grocery store,
different kinds of things, and we're actively looking to see if that predicts
what they actually eat.
This next question is for Dr. Chang.
Can you talk more about how you are training ethnicity-specific
aggregate social determinant of health scores?
Sure. So we're looking at the various components for specific racial ethnic
groups. So for example, I just gave you one example for looking
at homeownership in comparison for
Black African American residents to the comparison of non-Hispanic
whites. We are looking at creating different measures specific for
Latino Hispanic population, for the Asian American, and the Native
Hawaiian Pacific Islanders, and we're doing separate latent class models
for analysis for each of those groups because we think that
perhaps these various domains could have different patterns and
influences. So they're all racial ethnic specific models.
And I can say one,
as I mentioned, that this work is being done in the MEC, which includes
largely
residents of the LA County region and Hawaii, and working with our community
advisory boards,
our first initial try at making these measures was using non-Hispanic white
groups as a reference group, and they really came back to us and pushed us
to think about the demographics within Hawaii, right?
I think those of you who are familiar with Hawaii, it's largely a
predominantly Asian American and Native Hawaiian Pacific Islander population.
And so with their feedback, we took that to heart.
We thought about it and then did various models, so now our reference group is not
non-Hispanic white. It's to all other groups.
So those measures
for the Hawaii specific area will use not just the non-Hispanic whites as
a comparator, it will use all other groups.
So that was a really informative guidance that we got
in thinking about specifically that specific population.
And so I think we know a lot of these measures are racial ethnic specific and
geographic specific.
Thank you. The next question is also for you.
For the survival analysis with redlining, did you look at other outcomes like
cancer related mortality versus overall survival?
Yes, we have, and see a similar pattern.
Thank you. Okay, next question's for me.
For working with UW, the University of Washington, to do
Epic-based interventions, could you share technical details, solve barriers
to make it happen? Sure, yeah. And whoever asked this, please feel
free to email me after. I'm happy to connect offline.
The first step was to get in
touch with our chief medical officer
at Fred Hutch, who facilitated introductions for me
to other individuals in leadership,
specifically related to Epic, and this was at Fred Hutch Cancer Center and
at UW Medicine. It was a very, very long process where
I had to propose my idea at many different levels
and
incorporate a lot of stakeholder feedback input from different
individuals. For example, sending patients information on how
to schedule a same-day virtual PCP appointment was something that our
clinical stakeholders really pushed for because they wanted to increase
healthcare services utilization.
Other barriers. Yeah.
It was just getting in touch with the right people,
and then it's been a pretty interesting process.
We're gearing up for year two, which I'm very thankful for, but
I learned a lot year one. Some things that I would
share that were challenges.
There are individuals in Epic in the back end who are doing all the
data engineering.
Because it's over 64,000 patients, they didn't want to blast everyone with so
much outreach, so they proposed a kind
of staggered outreach method where patients received an
email if they had an email on file. If they didn't have an email on file, then they
received a text message. But I think because so many people are on their
phones nowadays, I'm going to propose to kind of switch that.
Text people first and then send an email.
I think that will help to increase engagement.
Another thing is we were only able to
track website clicks to our education website for air
quality likeEvidence-based strategies for
individuals who clicked on the website link from email.
So that's something that I hope to kind of improve upon this round.
And also, given more time, our Epic team said that they
could push a survey. So there's pushing outreach,
"Click on this link, and click on this other link to schedule a same-day
PCP appointment." But then they could also push a survey
to ask the patient, "Oh, so did you download the air quality index?"
or "Did you build your own portable air cleaner?" etc.
So I think that would just add like another
dimension to this. Okay, the next question: could you
expand on possibilities... Oh, we have four minutes left.
I've chaired
this similar sort of session three years now.
This is the most amount of questions I've ever had, so thank you so much.
Thank you. I appreciate it. It must be pretty nice to just use the QR code.
Could you expand on possibilities for community advisory board engagement for
choosing which environmental variables are useful to investigate?
So for our geospatial web app, the GeoX map,
GeoExposome map,
the Fred Hutch Office of Community Outreach and Engagement
facilitated meetings between our lab and each of the
community advisory boards. So we had to get on the agenda.
The agenda really fills up. And they also gave us a
tip sheet on how exactly to frame
GeoX map, what questions we really would like feedback
on.
Let's see, what else?
And yeah, so
through that process,
community members, cancer patients, advocates, individuals in
government just asked us what variables they would
like to see in GeoX map to help with their
work. For example, some cabs
asked for land use, land cover related to urban design.
They asked for
geospatial data on microplastics,
on federally qualified health centers.
So that was sort of the process for us.
I don't know if you wanted to speak to anything, Iona, on your-
I think,
for our studies, we do have a set of neighborhood measures that we've defined, but
they've come back to us and brought their feedback on what they
see in their neighborhood they'd like us to consider.
And as feasible, we try to incorporate those in our work.
Awesome.
Is there any geospatial data on equitable representation on clinical
trials?
I am not particularly familiar with that. Are you?
Geospatial data.
Yes, geospatial.
No, not that I'm familiar with.
Yeah. No, not to our knowledge.
A lot of areas in the Mountain West are not green, but they are certainly
awe-inspiring. How is this kind of natural brown space measured?
To Jamie.
Yeah. I think it was one-
Yeah.
We get it every time.
I think that's what we're looking at with some of these sort of ground level
measures. It's really hard. We have a bunch of researchers in our group who are
from Arizona, and they're like, "It's not green, but it's still pretty." And I'm
like, "I'm not saying green. This is pretty." And NDVI is certainly not a
measure of aesthetics. And so I think there's actually a whole
series of AI-based training maps where people are showing individuals two
images and asking them questions like, "Which one is safer?" "Which one is
more beautiful?" "Which one makes you want to be more physically active?" All these
different sort of feelings-based measures.
And so I would say look forward to those because I think it's going to be...
I don't think awe-inspiring is one of them, but beauty is definitely one.
And so, there's a lot of research that's about to come out with those
sorts of measures.
But yeah, Mountain West, very beautiful, though, Dominique.
Thank you. All right, we have one minute left, so one more question.
And if we didn't get to your question, please feel free to reach out to us.
So last question we could take. Opportunities to integrate geospatial data
sources across the life course to identify critical exposure
windows.
GUTS or Nurses' 3, they're asking, right, so if you want.
So in two of the cohorts that we have at Harvard,
the Growing Up Today study, they're the kids of the Nurses' Health Study Too, so
we've been following them since they were
in utero. So they are now reaching their early 30s and 40s, so we're starting to
launch research on
early onset cancers in that group, looking at their whole life course.
And in the Nurses' Health Study 3, which is currently enrolling, the same thing.
We're actually collecting lifetime residential histories with the goal of being
able to put together,
and the average age in that cohort is about 45.
So again, we're really in the heart of the early onset cancer story for
those two cohorts. But if you want to answer those questions, just
reach out.
How many participants are in Nurses' 3 and GUTS?
GUTS is 28,000, and Nurses 3, as of last week,
was 52,000, with a goal of 100,000.
Wow.
So if you know a nurse,
send them my way.
All right. It's 2:30. Thank you so much for coming. Thank you for the questions.
Appreciate it.